[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing some exciting harry potter
news that's right just earlier today we
got the second official trailer for the
upcoming fantastic beasts film fantastic
beasts 3 the secrets of dumbledore we
were supposed to get the trailer on the
24th not sure what happened there but
that's not important anymore what's
important is that it's here if you
haven't seen the trailer yet i've got it
posted on my channel so go watch that
first but if you have seen it which i'm
assuming you have if you're here stay
right here because i'm going to be doing
a trailer breakdown this is perhaps the
most comprehensive trailer so far and i
won't keep you waiting any longer let's
dive in
memory is everything that's the first
line we're hit with as a rendition of
the iconic hedwig's theme plays in the
background it's dumbledore's voice we
see hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry then we see dumbledore staring
into his pensive magical artifact used
to review and store memories what
aspects of his past is dumbledore
looking at
without it we leave the fate of our
world to chance dumbledore continues and
the trailer cuts to a young dumbledore
looking rather anxious next we see a
young woman it looks to be a young
maneuver mcgonagall a dumbledore's
doorstep telling him i'm sorry to
disturb you albus but i've just received
troubling news tell me what is it
dumbledore replies it's grindelwald the
trailer then shifts to a shot of
grindelwald's castle nurmengard which is
located in the austrian alps
nurmengard was used by grindelwald to
hold prisoners as well as serve as base
of operations for him and his followers
next we see grindelwald himself in deep
thought next we see credence sporting
his new long hair being paid a visit
from a phoenix we don't know for sure
yet but i think this phoenix is probably
fawkes the pair appeared to have a close
relationship the time is close my
brothers and sisters we hear grindelwald
say as we see newt walking up to some
kind of rally i know that the film is
set somewhere in bhutan a landlocked
country in the eastern himalayas located
between china and india so i'd be
willing to bet that this is where newt
is here as topographically it would make
sense newt looks pretty concerned here
so i'm positive this is some kind of
grinder world campaign rally our war
with the muggles begins today
grindelwald enthusiastically shouts out
to the crowd prompting witches and
wizards to cheer and fire their wands
into the air the spells being fired into
the air also appear to create some sort
of green pattern one which i happen to
know something about this is a logo for
the alliance an association of seditious
witches and wizards who followed gaelic
grindelwald in the early 20th century
the fanatics dedicated to grindelwald's
ideology of wizarding supremacy referred
to themselves as his acolytes but it's
important to note that many young and
idealistic witches and wizards were
taken in by grindelwald's charisma not
truly understanding the ramifications of
their actions the main goal of the
alliance was to expose the world
wizarding community and provoke a war
with non-magic people with intent to
overturn the international statute of
wizarding secrecy and force the
non-magical population into slavery
under their motto for the greater good
the world as we know it is coming undone
says dumbledore as we see grindelwald
extracting memories or at least i think
that's what he's doing from the head of
use of karma i say this because it looks
identical to when slughorn's memories
were taken from his head in the blood
prince if we're to defeat him you have
to trust me says dumbledore as we
witness dumbledore defending against
some kind of a spell finded him by
credence next we see jacob walking
towards his bakery and away from you
lally hicks a new protagonist that we've
only seen a small amount so far
eulali makes a brief cameo in fantastic
beasts the crimes of grindelwald when
she converses with nicola flamel via his
magic book but that role wasn't very big
and reportedly yulali is going to have a
much more significant role in the
upcoming film
jacob appears to be walking away from
you lalali with his tail between his
legs stating i want out i guess
everything has become far too much for
him to cope ully on the other hand isn't
having any of it stating mr kowalski we
need you
jacob is a no match right how could he
possibly be of pivotal importance when
it comes to defeating grindelwald i
guess we'll find out next we see
something truly bizarre on what appears
to be a train newt saying to jacob
dumbledore asked that i give you
something right before pulling out a
wand and handing it to him i really
don't know what this means for jacob's
character as a wand is useless in the
hands of a true muggle does this mean
that jacob has nascent magical ability
is he a squib also whose wand is this is
it grindelwald's old wand i actually
made a full video on jacob possessing
the wand which i'll link in the
description this is the team that's
going to take down the most dangerous
dark wizard in over a century is the
next line we delivered as we're given
quick cuts of various scenes first newt
jacob and yulali walking hurriedly
through a hallway before being stopped
in their tracks by some kind of magical
door and next we see grindelwald and his
acolytes standing in formation queenie
included what's interesting about this
group is that yusuf karma also appears
to be there and he's one of the good
guys right i'm willing to bet here that
grindelwald has extracted yusuf's good
memories perhaps via obliviate and use
the imperious curse on him putting him
entirely under his control unforgivable
curses don't apply to dark wizards like
grindelwald or maybe but less likely
yusuf karma isn't so good after all
who wouldn't like our chances we're here
as jacob giggles in the train
next up we see who has been revealed to
be a young aberforth dumbledore staring
into a mirror as words begin to form
though the sentence is incomplete we're
given a little bit of it
do you know is the clear part but from
there it gets a little messy i can only
safely theorize that it says do you know
who is but i don't know where to go from
there this mirror if you didn't know is
of course a two-way mirror one in a pair
of mirrors that are magically connected
this type of magical artifact allows
people to communicate with each other
while in different locations immediately
after seeing ab forth it cuts to albus
so clearly the two are using mirrors to
communicate next we see bunty mute's
assistant looking at newt quite firmly
and saying no one can know everything
not even you
given the absence of tina goldstein a
major character in the fantastic beasts
films from any of the trailers so far
i'm willing to bet that tina has taken
polyjuice potion to assume the form of
bunty i say this because bunty is quite
an unassuming figure and by taking on
her form it may allow tina to work more
effectively in the shadows this is also
the only reason i can think of that tina
isn't around queenie tina's sister is of
course on the other side now which
certainly complicates things next we
hear dumbledore saying what you're doing
is madness following by more grindelwald
rallies and alliance logos and then for
the first time ever we see dumbledore
and grindelwald sitting down face to
face with one another grindelwald says
to albus rather ominously with or
without you i'll burn down their world
next up we hear dumbledore saying
dangerous times favor dangerous men as
he leads eulally hicks jacob theseus and
newt towards the room of requirement
bunty is also there before the others i
might add and no tina so clearly this is
tina in disguise
right dumbledore motions his head
towards some kind of rotating ancient
pillar or beam which seems to act as a
port key i know that a subscriber
commented more information on this
pillar as it's a real thing which
pertains to nepalese culture but can't
seem to remember the details it does
have a name and it is a real thing maybe
just not a port key if by tea time all
of us are still alive we should consider
our efforts a success mr kowalski says
dumbledore reaching for jacob's hand
jacob says my pleasure which i suppose
suggests he's no longer feeling
ambivalent towards helping everyone out
next up we see a bunch of epic battle
sequences between none other than
credence barebone and albus dumbledore
dumbledore is clearly the more powerful
wizard and we see him deliberating on
whether or not he should deliver a final
blow to credence who he's holding on the
ground this scene looks epic back to
albus in grindelwald chatting
grindelwald drops a massive line saying
it was you who said we would reshape the
world this suggests that perhaps
grindelwald's plan of restructuring the
world for the greater good was actually
initially more driven by albus maybe
albus was the more evil of the pair to
begin with only changing his perspective
after the death of his sister which
hasn't been touched on yet i might add
next we see dumbledore analyzing what
appears to be a kind of pendant this
pendant however is certainly no ordinary
piece of jewelry as it actually relates
to the blood pact the dumbledore has
with grindelwald sealed by blood with
dumbledore analyzing it quite so closely
it could suggest that he's trying to
figure out how to break it and i think
he figures it out because there's a
scene further along in the trailer which
strongly suggests it's been broken more
on that in a second next we see newt
with pickett in the forest battling
against credence vinda rosier and
perhaps other acolytes
following this we see grindelwald in
some kind of a bath looking annoyed and
casting a spell at what appears to be
credence just before apparating in front
of him and choking him i wonder what
this could mean for their relationship
this scene is full of tension
then we see what appears to be ulalli
and theseus taking care of business and
fighting off bad guys then at two
minutes we see something falling into a
pit not sure exactly what i'm looking at
here
following that we see a niffler running
at full speed with picket on his back
who is holding a wand i wonder who's
wand that could be what happens next is
huge it's dumbledore in grindelwald
dueling this is huge for a number of
reasons first of all it means that the
blood pact has been broken the blood
pact that the men shared forbade them
from fighting each other so if they're
fighting it must be over and done with
at least i think so i'm really really
excited for this battle sequence i'm
sure it's going to be epic but i'm also
a little bit disappointed because
dumbledore and grindelwald dueling
likely indicates the end of the
fantastic beasts series after this film
we know that grindelwald is eventually
defeated by dumbledore and a jewel and
i'm not confident that two more films
will follow anymore next up we see a
bunch of characters reacting to the
jewel including liu tao an asian wizard
an acolyte of grindelwald's as well as
the never before seen vicencia santos
played by the actress maria fernanda
candido banners with vicenzia's name on
it have been seen in the teasers
trailers so far and it appears that she
will be running for the post of supreme
mugwump of the international
confederation of wizards during the film
a powerful ally for grindelwald to have
next up we see jacob and more
grindelwald acolytes then we see the
protagonists battling with what appears
to be a blast ended screwed of all
creatures hackard's favorite
next up we see theseus falling but it
looks like he's safe as mute is holding
his hand then we see more credence and
dumbledore fighting but we know how that
turns out for credence things are not
quite what they appear dumbledore says
as he stands with the phoenix flying in
front of him now on his side is this
forks longer video on this aspect of the
trailer to follow next we see jacob
causing all sorts of mayhem with his
wand and attacking queenie despite the
chaos of the magic he's producing it
appears to be somewhat concentrated
almost as if jacob is magical but just
untrained what does this mean the
trailer ends with jacob staring at
dumbledore holding a wand and saying can
i keep this
and that's it for now this is more of
just a cursory look at the trailer but
rest assured i'll be breaking down the
parts of the trailer that i found most
interesting and making some separate
more elaborate videos as well stay tuned
also what did i miss did i get anything
wrong comment down below if you enjoyed
the content please like the video and
subscribe to the channel to support
future content until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
[Music]